[Music]
and now part two of sarah carter's
exclusive reporting on the fentanyl
crisis in this country now taking us
inside a texas dps drug warehouse you
don't want you do not want to miss this
take a look we're in our dps crime lab
where the drugs that are seized from our
dps personnel is brought to this
location where we then have our crime
lab scientists they do the drug analysis
on these drugs and approximately just
we're talking about various drugs
marijuana cocaine
heroin methamphetamine and some fentanyl
there's approximately well over maybe a
little over 20 000 pounds of different
drugs that are here in this facility
right now in this facility alone so how
much would that be worth um possibly on
the street do we have an idea you're
talking tens of millions of dollars that
were as far as the value of these drugs
that are in this in this facility right
now and some of the biggest issues i
think facing our nation right now
and that's a crisis of fentanyl you're
right on point so that's what we're
seeing these uh these counterfeit pills
that are being manufactured by the drug
trafficking organizations we know that
the precursors are coming from china
into mexico and once the cartels get a
hold of those precursors they then
synthesize and manufacture that drug and
then move it across into our across into
our states and that's what we're seeing
now with these counterfeit pills and
again it's affecting everyone it's
killing thousands of americans because a
lot of these individuals do not know
what kind of drugs they're ingesting
when it comes to these pills no i've had
the opportunity to talk to parents
whose children
have taken a pill
at a party right
they were not known drug addicts their
kids did not use drugs regularly maybe
it was a recreational one-time use
and they've died yes and that's one
thing that's very important as
as a father and of course those that
have family we need to educate and
spread this awareness to our children uh
to our family to our friends about this
lethal drug that's coming across because
it's killing thousands of americans and
those young adults that are in colleges
right now
that are being presented with these
pills that they may think is some type
of pain medication or some type of
stimulant to keep them awake one of the
cases the fact of the matter is that
they're these men of these uh
counterfeit pills are killing thousands
of americans and they're not they're not
aware of what they're ingesting but
again it's all falling back into these
black border policies the fact that the
federal government has not taken any
action at all whatsoever and they're
allowing these drug trafficking
organizations to profit off of this
current illegal immigrants that are
coming across but also the drugs that
are coming across and they're not taking
any action whatsoever to safeguard
americans and to safeguard the border
and that's why we continue to step in
and take action uh to so we can
safeguard our our texans and also the
rest of the country
sarah carter joins us now investigative
reporter i you know i had i went into a
drug warehouse uh years ago when i've
been down on the border like you have
been many times about 14 times
and when i saw this warehouse first if
you can get through the stench of it
it's floor-to-ceiling drugs the
difference with fentanyl is you pointed
it out last night if you got you know a
grain of salt two grains of salt maximum
you know
it'll kill a 250-pound man
correct correct and that's what the law
enforcement officials here in texas and
across the country as well as those that
worked in the crime labs last night were
trying to send out the warning and
parents are also sending out that
warning sean so many parents that have
lost their children over 93 000
overdoses and deaths last year and i've
heard according to the coroner in
franklin county ohio those numbers are
far exceeded this year in 2021 so
they're very very concerned china and
the mexican cartels remain the major
players they are the primary
distributors of illicit fentanyl in the
united states and the pills sean look
identical to the pills that are
prescribed by a regular doctor so you
would see an oxycontin or a fentanyl
like i saw at the crime lab it would
look exactly like the pills that are
prescribed so no one can tell the
difference and this is what parents and
law enforcement officials want people to
know across the country talk to your
children talk to your friends talk to
your family let them know that if you
take a pill that is not prescribed by
your doctor you are literally playing
russian roulette with your life these
are poison and people are dying and you
know what it's happening it's the number
one killer of of people what 18 and 34
in the country right now
uh right
it's a tragedy
it's a tragedy and it's also preventable
anyway great reporting uh we'll have
part three tomorrow night hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else